[Music]
i'm
on a couple of these shows here um
instead of taking a third call i want to
get some of these emails folks because i
say stuff all the time and then folks
write in like you say this all the time
what do you mean by this or by that you
always talk about
kids have a role and talk about
relational iq what are you talking about
i think it's fair just to set context
um what kind of what i'm talking about
so
um this question comes from katie
hello catherine
i'm assuming you're a catherine if
you're just a regular katie shake it off
oh my gosh i love taylor swift too all
right katie asks what is relational iq
you say it all the time but i have no
idea what it means
[Laughter]
i asked that like in a in a
snarky voice like the way i'm reading
this is like katie's like you're kind of
an idiot why do you always say this i
don't know what you're talking about but
it could be that katie's like really
brilliant and it's like never heard of
this it's not in a textbook what do you
mean
here's what i mean katie
relational iq is
simply
who are you in relationship to those
around you
who's your community your personal your
neighborhood your nation your spiritual
community
where can you be vulnerable where do you
have congruence and authenticity what i
mean by that is where can you be fully
you
who gets the real you
is that just one friend in one place
is that just your
wife just your husband
or can you pretty much be the same
person at work as you are at home as you
are with your friends as you are at the
grocery store that's congruence can i
just be myself in all these places and
if i can't why not
what have you contributed to this
community what do you contribute to this
community on an ongoing basis and what
do you take from this community
are you a leech
are you the person that everyone is
always pouring into and you just got
holes in the bottom of your bucket and
everything's always running through you
i need more i need more or
like the last caller are you the person
that makes sure everybody else's bucket
is full even if it means dumping yours
out so that they've got something
so when i talk about relational iq i'm
talking about
how do you show up how do you come
across to those people in your life
whether you work with them you
drive with them you sit by them at the
grocery store you mow your lawn next to
theirs how do you set boundaries how do
you honor other people's boundaries how
do you love yourself your immediate
circle and how do you show up for
strangers in the world
and relational iq asks
how do other people experience me and
how do i experience other people
here's a good example
i am
exhausted
last night i was up to 1 am finishing up
um book edits i thought the book addicts
were gonna take two hours they took
eight
on a one chapter just grinding it out on
one particular chapter
shocking i talked too much and so i got
it back and needed to cut like 3000
words
um so i'm cutting and cutting and
cutting and then trying to reorient and
because one chapter one section leads to
another section i gotta adjust that
section and completely cut this one out
and then it's like now i gotta put them
back in
hours and hours and hours
my relational iq asks
when my kids walk in am i putting just
this thing down and being a present with
my kids
i happen to be editing right in the
middle of the living room which made me
the epicenter of all these other people
all these other relationships
so i'm this big pulsing
just beacon of frustration and beacon of
i'm locked in and zoned into something
and my kids are bouncing off my
electric force field
saying oh dad's radioactive hey dad you
want to play hey dad um look at this
maybe if i cry dad will look at me maybe
if i break something that'll look at me
and my wife is tiptoeing around the
house because she's like i don't know if
that is a bug zapper i don't know if
that pulse of energy is anger or rage or
just completely focused she's a writer
too so she understands me when you get
locked in you get locked in
and
or is that a cry for help that's
probably a little bit of all that stuff
i didn't have good relational iq last
night
relational iq would have been i don't
want to be the epicenter of i don't want
my energy to screw up everybody's night
and i know i'm gonna have a night where
i gotta grind something out for a while
so i should have gone down in the
basement i should have stayed at work
i should have said hey i love you guys i
miss you guys i'm gonna send flowers or
i'll be home later tonight you'll have
the best night ever go out to dinner and
have a great time
um i got a project i got to finish but
instead i tried to do it all that was
bad relational iq because then my son
ends up just going in his room shutting
the door going to bed early like
i'd rather not engage with this my
daughter
if she feels tension she's all in
and then she ends up a
crying mess and then i try to oversolve
the cry and then my wife's like hey i've
got this you get back to do it which
then i'm like oh because i can't pic
bad relation like you good relation iq
is
how am i feeling today how's the world
going to experience me how do i change
my attitude how do i know hey i'm
running kind of hot so if somebody runs
in and goes hey i need to do this that
i'm not going to lash out at them and
bite their head off i'm going to say
[Applause]
yeah let me get right on that or hey can
you run that by so-and-so because i
don't have the bandwidth take care of it
today
relation iq is knowing how i'm going to
interact with other people and
understanding that other people may be
running hot so when i say hey i needed
this a week ago and it's late and they
snap at me going that's probably not
about me
probably not about me i got a lot going
on um i'm gonna circle back um i'm gonna
ask you to be respectful when we talk
but i'm gonna circle back relation like
you how do i experience the world and
how's the world experience me in all
these areas personal neighborhood nation
spiritual i know some days 99 of them i
don't need to go check in on the news
a it's nonsense it's bullcrap it's not
real they're trying to get me riled up
and
um it's gonna make me respond to other
people negatively not good ways so i'm
just gonna roll off
what conversations am i avoiding which
conversations am i having
relational iq is how you show up for
those you care about which should be
everyone
how do you respond to conflict how do
you support those you love
that when i say relational iq is what
i'm talking about
if you want to have a good relation like
you it all starts with you going back to
yourself and saying
can i identify my body can i be honest
and understand when i'm bringing
my
shenanigans my pain my trauma my lack of
sleep my poor nutrition my
feeling good my excitement to a
situation
and
can i respond in a way that is dignified
and kind
and yet
holds my boundaries to other people
what are my boundaries what does
kindness look like for me what does
respect look like for me that's
relational iq
hope that helps katie thanks for writing
in